instigate the extract of  old radios yeah I have a bad feeling  love it  behold my evil extractor he hangs over  ends the machine with the incas a sound  it's double cross all signs pointing to  to face I won't rest until we get to the  bottom of this  the game is a flood mr. Spence get the  let out or I'll put them later in this I  insist you stop this fact not pretty boy  we had a deal  going once going twice sold to all the  villains of Gotham soon the secret will  be exposed for all of Gotham to see  to the Batmobile  start side up get the boys  [Music]  you'll never take me alive keep coppers  Furby stay strong  wakey-wakey burn boy now it's your turn  Robin the boy gimme big you'll never  figure out how to use that without Hugo  Strange you know that they say did your  catechism in the horrible lab experiment  join them